my name
is sebastian miailov and i
bring to you along with the world
champion
magnus carson the wonderful app tactics
frenzy sold millions of unique
high quality and entertaining chess
puzzles
that have all been quality checked by
strong
grandmasters like even with the camera
and good stuff song become a member
today
and compete for monthly prizes
sponsored by chessable just24
magnus trainer and of course king
himself magnus carson
we have made sure that no matter how
good you are at chess
you can enjoy this app and get
the challenge of your life alireza aruja
alexander grishik sergey karjakin among
a lot of the lead players they all love
the app
and i can assure you you will as well
download the app today and become a
chess
champion
[Music]
hello ladies and gentlemen
and let's
start so
everyone will see random
and now we go and
winning painting
let's make some pink between a5
and a6 good one
okay okay i'm not afraid
yes yes
yes
okay i think it's
theoretical position or very close to
the
theoretical one
yeah it should be seven is better
okay f6
sorry guys um
actually i'm not very experienced on
such things so i'm not expecting a high
score
no no high score today
but at least i found this skill
and this is cute
who is going where playing with black
so 951 check
it's important and
this i win
made mission e5
defend okay
[Music]
i guess yeah how are we
okay
this one doesn't look so good but we
need one helps
and we crush
the defensive bones not the defense but
the most
important pound well we can win a bishop
that's zombie seven it's really good
so
what if we play
what if we play what
[Music]
sorry i don't see
should i take and play no
but what should i do okay i'm trying to
be honest with you people
uh if i don't see a sa don't see arrow
okay
guys it's probably taken don't
play for but i don't know
yeah well this was
complicated so
97 is coming
okay and
no still made yes
yes
just take
okay um
i don't know
good day
save the position
and this is king a6
[Music]
yeah it's fun funny position
and
okay
but what else at the same time
and when you want
okay should sync for so long go
punish hello to you
and so
i'm playing like this
i'll find xc6
g5 normally it's 95 but this time
right and swinging
away
so what what should i do
[Music]
i don't have so much name
oh but knight g4 it was fine what was
the problem
what was the problem what was the
problem
no no ah
i was going to play rupees one okay
anyway anyway it was fun and
i enjoyed thank you guys
[Music]
you